today on the matt walsh show camila
harris perhaps the most inauthentic
politician in america today and that's
saying something is now inventing
anecdotes about her childhood
by plagiarizing martin luther king jr
apparently
also five headlines including antifa
thugs harassing
senator hawley's wife and baby and a
hollywood actress brags about her gay
gender fluid 12 year old and our daily
cancellation
i will cancel tipping i'm usually a big
tipper but i think it's gotten out of
hand
i have to cancel it i'll explain why all
of that and much more today
on the matt walsh show
well one thing we can say about the past
year one positive thing in my view that
we can say is that it has made people
think about consider explore
homeschooling which is a great option i
think
and to the parent parents listening who
are concerned about the coming school
semester for their school-aged children
there's a new option for homeschooling
it's called home school magnet
with school schedules always changing in
the challenge of so-called zoom school
which is uh you know not a great option
for a lot of kids now is the perfect
time to consider homeschooling
homeschool magnet supports homeschooling
families by providing students with
instruction from world-class credential
teachers
in a remote classroom with their peers
each student will receive quality
instruction in the four subject areas
math english language arts science and
social studies you get those core four
core subjects
parents ultimately have the freedom to
involve their student in as much or as
little learning as they prefer based on
each student's learning goals so
you as the parent and this is what
homeschooling is supposed to be right
you as the parent
have that kind of control and you know
your kid better than anybody else does
so you can figure out what your kid
needs other online schools exist of
course but
school magnet is unique even though home
school magnet
includes a robust a robust online
learning environment each student works
from real physical learning materials
guided by video instruction from their
teachers
homeschool magnet only a fraction of the
cost of private schools and the
money-back guarantee upon enrollment
means
that this choice is risk-free it's
something to really explore
and this makes it even better you can
save 10 for every child when you use
promo code walsh when you enroll
what you want to do is go to homeschool
dot
that's homeschoolmagnet.com you can
enroll for the 2021 spring semester
and use promo code walsh for 10 off well
ever since the announcement that camila
harris would be joe biden's vice
presidential
nominee there's been a non-stop flow of
worshipful
articles and essays from the bootlicking
media trying to convince us to see this
vapid unimpressive bureaucrat as a
civil rights pioneer and a transcendent
political leader
truly of all the false absurdities that
the media has insisted we take seriously
in recent years
none have been as false and absurd as
this now in the
initial title wave of fawning camila
harris
hagiographies a particularly sickening
and yet somehow still hilarious i think
example
was originally lost in the shuffle this
was published back on october 6
a piece in l titled camilla harris is
our new vice president-elect
and it's finally gone viral this week
for all the wrong reasons
author ashley c ford reporting with the
critical objectivity of a 16 year old
girl profiling harry styles for her high
school newspaper tells us
in the subheading that harris has been
fighting for justice and freedom
since birth since birth those are quotes
now i have four children myself and in
my experience
infants just lounge around all day
defecate in their pants
cry when they're hungry i have never
seen an infant demonstrate
any real interest in justice or freedom
but then again
none of my children are like camilla
harris or so i pray
and the first paragraph of the piece
we're given an example supposed example
of what kamela's childhood freedom
fighting supposedly looked like
and here's what it says quote senator
camilla harris
started her life's work young she laughs
from her gut the way you would with
family as she remembers being wheeled
through an oakland california civil
rights march in a stroller
with no straps with her parents and her
uncle at some point she fell from the
stroller
few safety regulations existed for
children's equipment back then
and the adults caught up in the rapture
of the protest just kept on marching
by the time they noticed little camilla
was gone and doubled back
she was understandably upset quoting
harris she says my mother tells the
story about how i'm fussing
and she's like baby what do you want
what do you need
and i just looked at her and i said
freedom
now i'm told that in the rough draft
version of the story the young camilla
smeared blue finger paint across half
her face
shouted they may take our lives but they
will never take our freedom
and then galloped into battle on her
trusty steed
now i'm joking of course kamel harris
would never plagiarize a mel gibson
movie
she will however plagiarize martin
luther king jr as some observant folks
on the internet pointed out
this anecdote from harris sounds
strikingly similar to one offered by mlk
to playboy
in 1965. here's what he said quote
i never will forget a moment in
birmingham when a white policeman
accosted a little negro
girl seven or eight years old who was
walking in a demonstration with her
mother
what do you want the policeman asked her
gruffly and the little girl looked him
straight in the eye and said
feed him she couldn't even pronounce it
but she knew
it was beautiful many times when i have
been in
been in sorely trying situations the
memory of that little one
comes to mind and has buoyed me now if
we can
fairly discount the possibility that the
little girl in king's story
was camila harris herself it would seem
that harris is
cobbling together a fake childhood and
in that same genre over the holidays
harris released a video
in commemoration of kwanzaa claiming
that she's been celebrating the holiday
her whole life
and recalling a time when quote multiple
generations including quote the elders
would gather together to engage in these
sacred quanzaic rituals uh here's here's
that
let's watch this happy holidays everyone
i wanted to take a moment to send my
warmest wishes to everyone
celebrating kwanzaa like so many other
holidays
we will be celebrating kwanzaa a little
differently this season
in our home we'll be doing it over zoom
you know my sister and i we grew up
celebrating kwanzaa
every year our family would in our
extended family we would gather around
across
multiple generations and we tell stories
the kids would sit on the carpet and the
elders would sit in chairs and
and we would like the candles and of
course afterwards have a beautiful meal
and of course there was always the
discussion of the seven principles
and my favorite i have to tell you was
always the one about self-determination
kujicalia and you know essentially it's
about
you know it's about be be and do
be the person you want to be and do the
things
you want to do and do the things that
need to be done
it's about not letting anyone write our
future for us
but instead going out and writing it for
ourselves and that principle motivates
me today
as we seek to confront the challenges
facing our country
and to build a brighter future for all
americans
so to everyone who is celebrating happy
kwanzaa from our family to yours
sure sure camilla yeah to everyone who's
celebrating
which would be nobody that was a happy
holidays to
nobody let's recall that kwanzaa was
invented in 1966
uh by by the way by a violent felon who
would go on to serve several years in
prison for kidnapping and torturing a
woman but that's neither here nor there
i suppose
well it's perhaps easy to understand why
harris would relate so much to something
that's meaningless and fake just like
herself
it's it's still it's hard to believe
that her whole family including
the elders so strictly observed a
holiday that didn't even exist when she
was born she was born in 1964.
this thing didn't didn't exist until
1966.
bear in mind that harris also claims to
have a deep and personal attachment to
christmas and hanukkah
what a fortunate coincidence that a
politician should happen to connect so
deeply to
every holiday and cultural tradition on
the calendar i just can't wait until may
5th when we'll no doubt find out about
her previously unknown mexican family
heritage
now going back to the l profile for a
moment we should note that um
the freedom story isn't the only
fabrication creating sort of a sense of
symmetry
the piece ends with an anecdote nearly
as fraudulent and ludicrous as the one
it began with
here's the one that it ends with it says
quote she camilla harris relays a story
about the night she became the second
black woman in history elected to the
u.s senate
in every one of my elections part of our
routine is we do a small
friends and family dinner before we go
to campaign night celebration
presumably the elders are at that the
elders are at that celebration too
sitting in there
in their chairs anyway she explains that
it was it was looking like the election
was going to be called for donald trump
quote my godson alexander who was seven
years old at the time
came up to me crying and said auntie
camella they're not going to let that
man win
are they and you know the babies in your
life
she closes her eyes and swallows i held
him
i mean it still brings me pain to
remember how he felt
and what it made me feel which is that i
need to protect this child
i had one way in my mind i thought that
evening would go
and then there was this way it turned
out and so by the time i took the stage
i had ripped up my notes and all i had
was alexander in my heart
and i took the podium and i said i
intend to fight
i intend to fight
if there's anything we know about
senator camilla harris it's that
when it comes to freedom she will fight
now by the way i just delivered that
line
from camille harris probably more
convincingly that she did
and i wasn't convincing at all of course
we can assume that the bit about the
seven-year-old godson distraught over
trump's election
never happened but the most egregious
fabrication is the final line and the
whole premise of the article that
camilla harris is a fighter for freedom
where's the evidence of that harris's
actual biography is far less inspiring
than the mythology that's currently
being constructed around her
in reality okay she began her political
career through a sexual relationship
with an influential and still married
politician
in california named willie brown brown
who was corrupt
dogged by fbi investigations throughout
his career
appointed harris to her first state
commission while they were still
together from there she would become
district attorney and then attorney
general of the state
but her record as attorney general was
criticized by many on the left
and by the same media that now hails her
as the second coming of the civil rights
pioneer she plagiarized
indeed it's it's one of the reasons why
she garnered almost no support during
her run for president
and flunked out of the race before
voting began
so despite what we're now being
instructed to believe
camilla harris is in reality a
pathological liar
a failed presidential candidate a
mediocre political talent at best
who slept her way to power achieved
little of note as a california
bureaucrat or united states senator and
was eventually given the vp nod by a man
who declared ahead of time
that he was making the choice based on
race and gender
but other than that sure she's an
inspiration
now let's get to our five headlines
so the uh georgia runoffs today by the
way so if you if you live in georgia
please go vote please go vote republican
and and i i all like all i can say to
you is if you've never believed or
trusted
anything i've ever said at least believe
this
that if you're a republican in georgia
the people who have been telling you who
call themselves republican or
conservative and have been telling you
not to vote or insinuating that maybe
you shouldn't vote
these are without exception
carnival barking grifters who don't care
at all about the future of this country
and are just in it for attention
or democrats in disguise without
exception
i mean i guess we could possibly leave
open the possibility for a third
category of just
absolute morons so maybe there are a few
of those but
that's basically all you got the people
that are telling you not to vote
and to allow the democrats to take over
the senate these are
grifters frauds morons
or all three if you yourself are not a
grifter fraud or [ __ ] then please go
vote because
um it would be fairly disastrous to have
the democrats
controlling the entire government for at
least two years that's not something we
can afford so please vote all right
number one senator josh hawley who will
be
objecting to election certification
tomorrow was not
at his home in dc last night but his
wife and baby
were at home and so were a bunch of
left-wing scumbags who came to his house
to harass them and here's how that went
we are not going to let people hold our
democracy hostage we are not going to
let them infringe on our rights
every ballot has been counted it is over
so when democracy
is under attack what do we do
when democracy is under
mandate
okay so you see you see there um
they're they're at the door
megaphones shouting and screaming in the
neighborhood at night
and he's not there his his uh his
he's in a different state his wife and
child could not travel with him
so his wife and child are there he's not
and they're shouting
now of course the claim from the left
today is oh they're being peaceful they
didn't uh you know they didn't they
didn't they didn't kill anybody
this time it's a very low bar now for
these uh
for these people but no
this is obviously intimidation but
there's there's only one reason
why you go uninvited to somebody's house
at night to scream at them there's only
one reason you do that and that is to
intimidate
them especially if their wife and child
is there and they're not even there
so this was an intimidation tactic the
kind of thing we see from the left all
the time
the kind of thing that is openly
encouraged by
leftist democrats politicians um
and uh it's one of these days it's going
to have a
disastrous end number two this is
interesting cardi b
was on instagram live doing some kind of
broadcast on new year's eve um and
singing along to her song wap
and now you you may recall this is a
song that that prompted criticism from
people like myself
people like ben shapiro uh and we were
mocked and made fun of we're used to it
i mean i could speak for myself i think
probably ben is too so
didn't really hurt my feelings but we
were we were attacked for criticizing
this songwop and saying that it's
that it's degrading to women and um and
in fact
part of our argument is it's not the
kind of song you'd want your daughter to
listen to
or to hear right and we were told
that's this is ridiculous it's
empowering it's a wonderful song
well apparently cardi b agrees with us
she's
the person who made the song she agrees
with us
because here she is uh singing along to
the song and then her daughter walks in
and watch what happens then watch
okay so she's singing to the song the
daughter walks in
she quickly turns it off and says no no
no and now she's ushering the child
looks like her daughter's about i don't
know she's probably your daughter's
about five years older so before five
years old you could easily say well it's
different because it's a it's a child
and of course this is and this is this
has been
the justification given by cardi b she
was she this this was
she was criticized for this and people
were pointing out seems like a kind of a
contradiction on your part because you
don't want your own daughter to hear the
song and she says oh i make songs for
adults
these are adult songs which
first of all can i just point out how
sad it is
that the word adult has now become
associated with
this kind of toxic sewage it should be
if you're making something for adults
it should be that it's intelligent and
substantive
and it would go over the heads of the
children that's why it's not for
children
right it's like russian literature is
not for children
because it's for adults because it's the
kids wouldn't understand it
it's too intelligent for them but now
when we say oh it's for adults we mean
it's actually
it's actually even dumber than the kinds
of things that we would let our kids
watch
but anyway is the issue just her age
so you say no i just don't want my
daughter to listen to it right now
okay well then i would ask you cardi b
or anyone else if you don't want your
daughter listening to that song
at the age of six or seven i agree i
don't want my seven-year-old daughter
listening to that
but my question is at what age do you
want your
your daughter to listen to that you
don't want to listen to it at seven
do you want her listening to the song at
12 do you
do you want her listening at 16 do you
want her listening when she's 30.
now when she's 30 you can't stop her
from listening but do you want her to is
that
is that the kind of thing is this the
kind of material is this the kind of
message that you would ever actually
want
your daughter to be exposed to
i'm not say you don't have to point well
we can we can't we can't protect our
kids from this forever eventually
i understand that but is there ever a
time you take a song like this
will there ever be a time in your
daughter's life
when you actually would really actively
want her to be exposed to it
i think unless you're an abusive parent
or an absolute creep
the answer is no of course you would
never actually want your daughter
listening to that whether you could stop
her or not
that's the point that's our whole
criticism
if there's something being put out into
the world
that no parent would ever actually want
their child
at any age to be exposed to
that should tell you something about
that material
just something to think about number
three here's a creepy psa from the
government in canada
um we'll just play this and then talk
about it check it out
every time you wear a mask remember it's
so one day
we can all go back to doing this and
this
every time you wash your hands remember
that eventually it'll all be worth it
for them
and them every time you hang out here
remember that at some point
we'll all be able to get together here
here
and here protect yourself and others
from kovid19
a message from the government of canada
yeah every time i see psas like this i
always think well i'm
i've been doing that kind of stuff the
whole time so not so much that well some
of that they're dancing i haven't really
been doing that
and we can't go to to uh sporting events
but
getting together with people getting
together with friends going to
restaurants
i'm doing that right now so
i think you can actually still do that
even when there is a virus out there
that's it's not the virus that's
stopping us from doing that it's the
government stopping us from doing that
so the government is saying we're
stopping you from doing this
but obey us on this piece over here
and do as you're told and then we'll let
you start doing this again
that's the part they leave out it's
we will let you do this once you do that
number four from the daily wire it says
actress and abortion activist bizzy
phillips
has revealed that her 12 year old child
is gay and uses they
them pronouns speaking on episode of her
podcast busy phillips is doing her best
that's the name of the podcast
um she said that her child birdie came
out as gay
uh she said quote for those of you who
are my friends listening at home this is
the first you're hearing that bertie is
gay and out
birdie told us at 10 years old and we
immediately uh we immediately knew
we knew that birdie knew so let's go to
a clip from the podcast now here here
she is busy phillips
recounting a conversation with her 12
year old daughter
who she saddled with the name birdie
which was really just the first
of many abuses it turns out listen to
this
bird said i said you know bird i've been
doing a bad job with the pronouns
because birdie said that
they would like their pronouns to be
they them
and i haven't been doing it and i said
because
like i have this um
public persona and i want birdie to be
in control
of their own narrative and not have to
answer to anybody outside
of our friends and family if they don't
want to
and then byrd was like
i don't give a [ __ ]
like i would i you can
talk about that i'm gay and out you can
talk about my pronouns i
that would be cool with me that's great
so i said okay
i'm just i'll i can talk about it on the
podcast
and bernie was like and brody was like
yeah talk about a podcast mom i'm like
okay throw my phone on the ground sorry
anyway so um
yeah it's been wild so birdie
my out kid
prefers they them i [ __ ] up sometimes
but we're i'm
trying my best yeah i i wish this was
similar to the camila harris situation
and i could say that this is an invented
conversation that she had with her 12
year old
or 12 year old daughter um
but i don't think it is i think that
unfortunately that conversation really
happened
where 12 year old daughter was telling
her her pronouns
and then when busy phillips asked
whether she could
reveal this on the podcast the child the
12 year old daughter responded
i don't give an f i think that
that's a real conversation because
that's the kind of mother that bizzy
phillips is now
it shouldn't surprise us as was noted
she's an abortion activist and uh
she's bragged in the past about getting
abortions so
this this is how she sees her children
she sees her children as unfortunately
many parents especially on the left do
in a dehumanized way you know she sees
her child as
either trash that can be discarded like
the one that she killed
or as political prop uh or even not a
political just a prop
something to be shown around
um an accessory maybe is a better word
for it
and that's what she's doing here kind of
like locking her daughter
in to this identity by announcing it
publicly
there's there's no good reason there's
no good loving
parenting sort of reason to take your
child's
confusion and they're working through it
and and you just broadcast it to the
entire world
that's not going to help you i mean even
even for a moment just
putting aside everything else and and um
pretending that it could be legitimate
for a 12 year old to identify as they
them or it could be legitimate for
anyone to identify as they then which of
course it isn't
because it doesn't mean anything but
putting that aside
just there's no reason to tell the world
about it
there's no reason to publicize it she's
12 years old for god's sake
how will it benefit her for the whole
world to know about this
busy phillips says well i asked her i
asked her and she said she doesn't give
an f
so i did it yeah once again
this is the theme we see so often
especially with
with uh with with parents who have
children who are gender confused
so often what we see are the parents
looking to the children for guidance
the parents saying to the kids you show
me the way you you
you tell me what i'm supposed to do here
i'll let you take the lead
no no that's not what you say to your 12
year old you
that's not what you say to your 12 year
old your 12 year old needs
you to be the adult your 12 year old
needs you
to be the rational one your 12 year old
needs you to be the one who can see
beyond the nose on your face who can
think in the long term
kids can't do that that's the point
psychologically they don't they don't
have the capacity yet
for things like long-term planning they
can't do that at 12 they can't
they can't do it at 16. they certainly
can't do it at seven or eight
or whatever their age now where kids are
just
quote unquote deciding they want to
transition they can't do they they don't
have the psychological
neurological capacity for it you do or
you're supposed to as an adult
so you're supposed to be the one who
says listen no i'm not going to put this
out there for the whole world we're
going to keep this between us
private and also you know you're
obviously confused you're working
through some things
let me help you out we'll take you to
counseling let's try
let's try to figure out what's really
going on here you're
you're a girl it's wonderful that you're
a girl but you don't want to
identify as a girl there's obviously
something happening here
so let's figure it out you take the
child to counseling you help them
if your child comes to you and says i'm
they them
that is your child saying i am confused
i don't understand i don't know who i am
and i don't know who i am because you
the parent have failed
it's your job to help me figure out who
i am
to help me figure out if i'm a girl what
it means to be a girl in the world
you're the mother that's what you're
supposed to be doing
that's what your child is really saying
to you only they're not saying
exactly that audibly because they don't
have the capacity to say it
they don't understand their own feelings
this kind of thing will never fail to
just infuriate me
especially as a parent i don't think you
need to be a parent to be disgusted and
infuriated by this kind of madness but
as a parent i just
i i have kids myself and the idea
of me turning to them for guidance
or the idea that they would make some
mostly incoherent declaration about
their own identity and i would just
take it seriously and assume that it's
that it's meaningful and just go with it
it's mind-boggling to me they're kids
i'm the adult that's the way the
relationship is supposed to work
all right let's go speaking of
mind-boggling but in a different way in
a better way in a good way
uh there's a book coming out which i
will be sure to purchase
uh titled extraterrestrial the first
sign of intelligent life beyond earth
and it's authored by a harvard professor
who says that alien life
has been confirmed he says that we we
know it's it's real it's been confirmed
we've already seen the evidence and he
makes a persuasive case in my mind it's
persuasive
though admittedly i'm mostly persuaded
because i really want
i'm persuaded by every ufo claim
basically because i want it to be true
and so i'm letting my emotions guide me
which is exactly what adults aren't
supposed to but in this case i think
i'll make an exception for myself
anyway here's the uh the report from fox
5 in new york
listen this is the very first object
that we have detected
from outside the solar system that
entered the solar system
and passed near the earth harvard
university astronomy department chair
avi loeb
also serves as director of the institute
for theory and computation
the founding director of the black hole
initiative and the chairs of both the
breakthrough starshard advisory
committee
and the national academy's board of
physics and astronomy next week a paper
he co-authored appears in the
astrophysical journal letters providing
one he would say the first scientific
explanation for a mysterious something
now named a muammua
that passed by earth on its journey from
another solar system
a year ago it happened to be very weird
weird first because of its shape
either very long or very flat based upon
the sunlight reflected from it
but most peculiarly amuamua appeared to
accelerate
we see such a an additional force in
comets
and that's due to the evaporation of ice
on the surface of the comet but
displayed no cometary tail or change in
its rotation
leaving the source of the push and the
identity of the object not only a
mystery
but one without seemingly any credible
explanations
until loeb's paper which hypothesizes
sunlight provided the extra push
and for that to be effective the object
needs to be very
thin uh less than a millimeter in
thickness
and sort of like a sail that is being
pushed by the light from the sun
what loeb is suggesting is that some
other living being not from this solar
system created that light sail which we
earthlings also aspire to build
and a muammua represents not a piece of
space rock but a highly technologically
advanced probe from some alien
civilization
i haven't seen any other compelling
possibility
at the moment i i'm sold completely
but again only because i want to be the
more critical side of my brain though
says that you know this is the kind of
thing that makes people
sometimes skeptical of scientists
because
what what do we really have here what
what we actually have
is a tiny from our perspective
as far as we could see this tiny
infinitesimal
blur on a screen you know some some
small object is out there millions of
miles away
in space and that's all we know that's
all we've got
and so this this harvard professor has
constructed this whole narrative around
he's wrote an entire science fiction
novel basically around that little blur
on the screen
and he's just he's proposing it as fact
like this is what happened it's a light
sail
from an extinct alien civilization
and but i mean i want to hear the whole
story i don't know if i really
you know it's i i like the story i want
to hear the story
whether it's true or not but it is uh it
is
it is fascinating stuff who knows it
could be
so you can't prove that it's not a light
sail from a from a
extinct alien civilization and that's
enough for me
personally you know these days lots of
people are
animal lovers pet owners pet people i
i'm not so much myself
but my wife is and we have a cat at home
and that's why
i know from my wife's perspective and if
you're a pet owner you know you have a
responsibility to take care of your
animal
and uh and to keep your pet healthy from
the beginning of the pandemic petsmart
has remained open making sure you can
get everything your pet needs
right when you need it at over 1600
convenient locations petsmart stores and
grooming salons
offer digital check-in curbside drop-off
and pickup and contactless payment as
well and now petsmart offers
free same-day delivery which is powered
by door dash through january 31st so you
can get everything your pet needs and
you don't have to leave
the home right to your door right when
you need it petsmart's associates really
love pets and they love caring for them
it's a big part of why they work there
and petsmart has made it safe and easy
for you to care for your pet too
online or in stores if you're interested
in contactless shopping which a lot of
people are just
order online at petsmart.com or on the
petsmart app
and enjoy easy curbside pickup or free
same day delivery
through january 31st and get everything
your pet needs go to
petsmart.com for more details again
that's petsmart.com
let's get to our daily cancellation
now today we're going to be canceling
tipping um
i am at this this moment calling for a
complete and total shutdown of tipping
until we figure out
what the hell is going on to paraphrase
donald trump now to be clear i i don't
consider myself to be a cheap person
growing up my dad would always tip 20 to
25
as a baseline starting point at
restaurants i have inherited this custom
and will also
generally tip 20 to 25 sometimes more
actually
partly as an act of generosity and
partly as an apology
because i have four young kids and as a
consequence we leave our tables looking
like a pack of wild dogs has just been
dining there
except the dogs at least would eat all
their chicken nuggets which is more than
i could say for my daughter but in any
case the point is
i have always tipped well i think and
i've tipped the pizza delivery guy well
also
and the cab or the uber driver and of
course if i'm staying at a fancy hotel
then i know i'm supposed to tip
basically everyone who happens to glance
at me
at fancy hotels employees will invent
weird and unnecessary things to do for
you
just so they can get a tip somebody will
like come to your room at 8 30 in the
morning
and spoon feed you granola and clip your
toenails
you're supposed to tip them five dollars
and i've always gone along with that
i've prided myself as a tipper but
recently i have reached my limits
because the problem is that now
everybody expects a tip
whereas before you were only supposed to
give a tip in certain limited and
specialized circumstances
now every person who rings up a purchase
at a cash register
or pours you a cup of coffee wants to be
tipped for their trouble
you know the the solicitation for tips
can come
in in only these mildly invasive ways
like you know there's a tip jar left out
on the counter
or sometimes in slightly more obnoxious
forms like when you're handed a receipt
or told to confirm your purchase on an
ipad that's a big one now
they flip the ipad around and there's a
there's you know you're supposed to
click through
how much gratuity do you want to leave
but sometimes and i've had this
experience more than once especially
recently
the person ringing up the purchase will
actually ask you outright
whether you would like to add a gratuity
like asking you verbally
applying social pressure and attempting
to make you look like a jerk to the
other customers in line if you say no
now fortunately in my case i'm used to
being a jerk in public so i have no
problem responding with
no i don't want to add a gratuity or the
more passive-aggressive
no but thanks for asking many kinder and
gentler people than myself however are
guilted into tipping a dollar or more on
a coffee
that's already twice as expensive as it
should be
the situation is entirely untenable the
average cost of living in america has
increased by upwards of 65 percent in
the last two years
because of excessive tipping don't
fact-check me on that figure it's
emotionally correct if not factually
correct
so i have to put it i have to put
tipping on probation
banning it across the board temporarily
until sanity can be restored to the
proceedings and here's some sanity
just because you work in customer
service doesn't mean you automatically
deserve a tip
you are getting paid a wage after all
customers are already paying for the
good or service you're providing
here's the way i look at it tipping
should only come into play if three
conditions are met number one
it's a low paying service job two
it's a service that i could not or would
not want to
perform myself and three my experience
as a customer can be greatly enhanced by
your excellent performance or
greatly diminished by your poor
performance so those are the three
conditions
this is why we should and always have
tipped waiters
waiter has a low paying job and you know
the fact that the customer is
at a sit-down restaurant means they
don't want to cook and serve themselves
and the quality of the customer's
experience at the restaurant is highly
dependent on the quality of the waiter's
service
a bad waiter means a bad time a good
waiter means a good time
barbers and pizza delivery guys also
meet all three conditions
but what about a cashier ringing up my
items at a grocery store
often they ask for a tip now too but
they shouldn't receive one because yes
condition one low paying job is met
but conditions two and three are not i
would gladly use the self-checkout if
it's an option
so it's not a service i couldn't or
wouldn't do myself and though there are
people who somehow find ways to be very
bad at running cash registers
there really isn't any way to be
excellent at it so my experience as a
customer
will be about the same with an excellent
cashier as it is with a mediocre one
the barista pouring my coffee also
should not be tipped because she fails
to meet all three conditions again
condition one is met okay low paying job
but i could without much trouble pour my
own coffee if given the option in fact
at some places
they'll just hand you the empty cup and
have you fill it yourself
yet even then they want a tip the simple
act of picking up an empty cup and doing
this
like just just that this is it this this
is what this is what earns you a tip now
here you go that'll be three extra
dollars
like you you get a financial bonus for
doing that
this system with the three conditions
i've outlined um also explains why we
don't tip say
airline pilots you know in their case
conditions two and three are met
i can't fly the plane myself and my
experience as a customer
would be quite unpleasant if the pilot
isn't good at his job but condition one
is not met airline pilots are paid
handsomely and for good reason
now the only category that throws my
system for a loop
are the endangered species known as
bathroom attendants they used to be a
lot more common than they are today but
you still find them sometimes
standing by the sinks at like a bar
or restaurant handing out towels and
mints i've always tipped them
even though i could quite easily grab my
own towel and i'm really not interested
in mints that have been saturating in
the fumes of
strange farts all day but i tip mainly
out of pity
because they have to stand there in the
bathroom experiencing the sounds and
smells of human waste
plopping ominously into toilets or near
toilets at any rate
an exception was made for bathroom
attendance but now everybody wants the
bathroom attendant exception
now everybody expects a tip even random
people online will post their venmo or
gofundme
soliciting funds for no reason after
having provided you absolutely no
service of any kind whatsoever
they just say hey by the way if you want
to give me some money here it is
it's not even tipping anymore this is
panhandling
and we have to pull back from it while
we still can before it gets so out of
hand that you'll be bankrupted just by
running errands for three hours on a
saturday afternoon
so tipping is canceled at least for now
and if you enjoyed what i had to say
here you can always
send me a few bucks through paypal or
venmo if you want if you want to give me
a tip
but otherwise tipping is cancelled
that's going to do it for us today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
production assistant mckenna waters the
matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
an old hack journalist calls trump's
latest leaked phone call
worse than watergate a democrat
congressman transgenders the word amen
and kamala harris steals a story from
martin luther king check it out on the
michael knowles show